look at you you made it to wednesday as
your reward i'm gonna tell you all about
the massive twitch leak when you're
finally gonna be able to hear what's
coming to animal crossing next month and
i'm gonna give you an update on the
rumored gta trilogy remaster my name is
devonte chisholm and you're watching
gamespot news
let's start with twitch confirming that
it has suffered a massive breach leading
to the release of sensitive information
including the app's source code streamer
payouts an amazon owned steam competitor
and potentially user's personal data in
a post on twitter the streaming giant
said it has teams working urgently to
understand the extent of the breach and
assure the twitch community that it will
update them as soon as additional
information is available the information
from the breach was made publicly
available via a 125 gigabyte turret link
posted to 4chan today along with
streamer payout information the league
data includes twitch's source code in
its entirety proprietary software used
by twitch and an unannounced competitor
to steam from amazon game studios
codenamed vapor which could combine many
of twitch's features with a digital
gaming storefront
so remember when nintendo teased in
animal crossing new horizons direct
during their september direct well we
finally got a date nintendo has
announced the digital event for animal
crossing new horizons will air on friday
october 15th at 7 a.m pacific time 10
a.m eastern time according to the
official animal crossing twitter account
the presentation will last around 20
minutes and will focus solely on quote
content coming to animal crossing new
horizons in november and based off the
teas in september you can expect to see
the roost an in-game coffee shop run by
a bird named brewster other than that
there has been no further indication as
to what new features are coming to the
game i feel so guilty for abandoning my
island but hopefully whatever's coming
in november
can bring me back in
and speaking of bringing me back there
is new evidence that rockstar is
preparing to transport all of us back to
their ps2 era classics according to the
members of the gta forums rockstar's own
rockstar game launcher for pc recently
received an update that contains
references to the rumored gta trilogy
remaster collection the update note
shows listings for quote unreal versions
of gta 3 vice city and san andreas this
matches what reports that those three
games are being remastered with epic's
unreal engine and bundled together to
celebrate the 20th anniversary of gta 3.
this development comes after a ratings
board in korea published a rating for
grand theft auto the trilogy the
definitive edition suggesting the
project is indeed real
but alright yesterday was the one week
anniversary of new world and to
celebrate the devs released patch notes
for the game's newest update an update
that largely focuses on bug fixes but
there are a few smaller quality of life
changes as well changes to the game's
afk system have been made in order to
ensure players can artificially stay afk
on high population servers with long
queue times players will now
automatically disconnect from the game
after being afk for 20 minutes down from
25 and changes have been made so that
the game can better detect those trying
to fool the game's system with simulated
mouse movement new world's first patch
also lays the groundwork for upcoming
free server transfers which were
announced shortly after the game's
launch in the wake of massive queue
times leave a comment down below letting
me know if you are going to take
advantage of that server transfer and
what your new world situation looks like
me for one i had to create a new
character on a different server because
the first one i picked
it was ridiculous i i just could never
get in at the end of the day if i was
playing early in the morning eastern
north american time
great end of the day
no forget about forget about it
couldn't do it
thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]
you